[Music]
I'm a creep and I'm preparing for this
segment I did a little research at what
I'm doing yeah as I do and I found a
picture of you from your college days
and yeah and now this is most of us are
embarrassed I don't think you should be
embarrassed you're look at that you're a
very very good-looking fellow in the
house oh you kind of look like a lesbian
yeah
[Applause]
really oh oh don't pull a muscle ah
screw stay back moaning that Angela that
laughs wash over me
yeah freshing know yourself first day
back take it easy
you seem like a nice fellow in that in
that picture tell us about yourself I'll
at least kick one person's ass you guys
keep this up I could get one of you
tough crowd I've seen him there they're
building my wife married that guy that's
all I know that's impressive right yeah
it all worked out for you what would you
like in college what kind of were you a
job cuz I gotta be honest with you I've
been out with you and your wife my wife
and I we've been out with you guys many
times actually and I'll tell you why so
many times we're still trying to figure
it out like what you mean you're a good
guy but she's pretty right yeah I know
and every night we ND we're like the
kool-aid yeah you say whenever my wife
comes and visits the show and she leaves
people just her like she's so pretty
and then they linger too long and look
at me oh we're not the only one to have
that reaction maybe he's funny at home
[Laughter]
what a dick every time I come out of
your Asian I have I mean to do I have to
call you a dick just it's what we do
it's our tradition afternoon dick hey I
don't care one more day care less what
were you like you were you uh a jock
yeah well I swim Irwin swam swam free
that was the USC sweatshirt I think that
was the swim team photo there that you
were looking at right sorry I cut it
there it is
yeah that's USC and I swam I was an art
student
oh you were artsy and a jock that's cool
see but why you I see in you I don't get
it but I'm the artsy jock I'm an
incredible I think I'm a sexual athlete
[Applause]
I'm counting oh I'm scared of girls when
the lights come down this thing comes
off let's shout the dang shabba-doo that
made no sense
what is Chevy tank keppa do cuz that's
what I do
your obvious that you're having someone
who really understands sex yeah
davon that's what I think sex is you
ever do that's gonna take off this year
t-shirts I make yourself a million bucks
yeah it's about time no it's alright you
want we're trying to get somewhere no
but I just I I admire you very much I
love your work I'm up here pal
no I'm talking printer I love you right
here are you looking at huh up here
Saturday
[Applause]
I am a big fan anyone who's not watching
justified as a fool I do love that show
so much thank you it is a great show
I'll tell you something I'm an actor so
you know I know so I'm like you know I'm
a little neurotic it's all about me and
I complain a lot but I also listen not
so much at home but like on the street
I'll tell you something yeah what I hear
on the street is nothing but great show
best show on TV hey you the guy on
justified right I love that show
nine times out of ten you realize that's
me putting on moustaches and coming
around it's exhausting keeping your ego
up have you noticed they're all six four
with orange hair
[Laughter]